[Music]
hey can we get real for a second we've
been friends for 10 years
i know that you don't like to talk about
your life
but a guy with a freaking machete
foreign arm just
[Music]
my father trained me to view the 10
rings greatest weapons
[Music]
[Applause]
how did you find me
i always know where my children are me
against the world i got my back against
the wall
seems like a nice fella
it's time to show the world
[Music]
you are a product of all who came before
you
[Music]
i must stop him hell yeah
if you got a problem
yeah you can hear
me marvel studios sean chi and the
legend of the ten reigns in theater
september 3rd
[Music]
our guest
[Music]
i'm looking for someone who can help me
gain an audience with the czar perhaps
you can be of assistance
i only make decisions when my stomach is
full or my balls are empty
well thank god dinner is being served
[Music]
small things
can grow into big problems
[Music]
we are the first independent
intelligence agency
while governments wait for orders
our people take action
welcome to the club
you're going to need a suit
very clever
time to dance
[Music]
stop [ __ ] about
[Applause]
[ __ ] this gentleman's shaped i'm gonna
love killing you
[Music]
i wish we'll see
[Music]
oh look at this this is a good one some
suggest that parker's powers include the
male spider's ability to hypnotize
females stop come on yes my spider lord
can we just like stay up here all day it
is so crazy down there
that's right folks spiderman is in fact
peter parker listen i did not kill
mysterio the drones did the drones that
are yours
does any part of you feel relieved about
all this what do you mean
now that everybody knows you don't
really have to hide or lie to people for
the record i never wanted to lie to you
but how do you tell someone that you're
spider-man
now everybody knows
but this isn't about me this is hurting
a lot of people
i've just been thinking about how to fix
all of this
so peter
why do i owe the pleasure i'm sorry to
bother you sir please be safe to have
the universe together i think we're
beyond you calling me sir okay stephen
that feels weird but i'll allow it
when mysterio revealed my identity my
entire life got screwed up
i was wondering if maybe you could make
it so that he never did
strange don't cast that spell
it's too dangerous
fine
i won't
the entire world is about to forget the
peter parker spider-man wait everyone
can't some people still know that's not
how the spell works
so mj's gonna forget about everything
we've ever been through stop tampering
with the spell oh my god ned he's my
best friend my aunt may should really
stop talking
what just happened
we tampered with the stability of space
time
multiverse is a concept about which we
know frighteningly level
the problem is you trying to live two
different lives
the longer you do it the more dangerous
it becomes
be careful what you wish for parker
hello peter
[Music]
[Music]
five years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe
not the people of this planet brought
everyone back with a snap of a finger
the sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin
how long do we have
seven days
we're eternals
[Music]
we came here seven thousand years ago
to protect humans from the deviants
[Music]
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
we were instructed not to interfere in
any human conflicts unless estevians are
involved
by who
[Music]
we need to find the others
i haven't seen some of them for
centuries
hi
hello
this is what the end of the world looks
like
at least we have front row seats
you know what's never saved the planet
you're sarcasm
[Music]
[Applause]
we have loved these people since the day
we arrived
when you love something
you protect it
[Applause]
you can't protect
any of them
[Music]
i bet you've built the perfect safe
house what's this even made of vibranium
fall collection
ikea
i really am glad you're here
i just want you to enjoy your weekend
[Music]
you taste like oregano
[Music]
you need to put all that away i haven't
had my coffee yet
excuse me
don't fail me no
dear jordan i don't fail just take one
look at your mother
marry me
yes
that will tell you what i think
beautiful is i'm ready
your father wrote that i'm ready
he wrote this whole thing just for you
[Music]
love is a choice jordan
and real love
means you have to sacrifice
but pain is temporary
real love lasts forever
but remember jordan
you have to fight for it
[Music]
see it exclusively in movie theaters
this christmas
lady here
we should be out there snacking on bad
guys
i am a predator
i need to be free you have got to get
control of your aggression
we will get hauled off into area 51.
live in my body you live by my walls i'm
sorry i don't know what came over me
please let me fix it so i can fix it
again
you are a loser
eddie brock
i want to give you my story
people love serial killers
cletus why me
that's mine
it's yours and what's yours
is mine
i have tasted blood before and that is
not it
all i ever wanted in this world
is carnage
i'm not a crazy man
real vengeful
everybody
i promise oh yeah
betty
you feel like home to me
like family
oh wow you could just say i'm happy for
you that was going to be us hey i'm
happy for you
god i'm so sorry i'm sorry just doing
some serious couples counseling
i am dark and this makes me squirrel
i am warning you once again i will not
warn you after that
get out of my azaleas i digged them yeah
it's not digged it's dark yes no you
didn't digged you dug i am dog
[Music]
myself
[Music]
they're waiting for you
[Music]
[Music]
they know everything
they don't
[Music]
it was a name that sounded so sweet so
seductive
synonymous with words
style
power
but that name was the curse too
i've been a gucci all my life
your name is in the history books
wow you are gucci you need to dress the
part
[Music]
gucci needs new blood
it's time to take out the trash
they're my family
you picked the real firecracker she's a
[Music]
it's handful good
i don't consider myself to be a
particularly ethical person
but i am fair
[Music]
can you keep a secret
father son and house
[Music]
this is it
dresses by ella
here's a laugh this girl fancies herself
a businessman
cinderella it's only my love for your
father rest is all that stands between
you and a life on the street
i have to make a life for myself i'll
sell one of my signature dresses soon
everyone will love my name
to make sure your nuptials are done
properly we shall hold a ball you shall
find a bride
cinderella you don't need to go to the
ball please step mother i spent weeks
making this dress my future depends on
it
i am your fabulous godmother do you want
to go to that ball and meet a bunch of
rich people who will change your life
yes i was just crying and singing about
it like two minutes ago then go you
shall
oh look at that this is different okay
dad you said you wanted to be a
businesswoman it's magic time oh me
where's my tail i can't balance without
my cat again
[Music]
hi would you like to dance right now
where did you get that dress i designed
it
i pick you to be my princess what about
my work i don't want a life stuck waving
from a royal box any more than a life
confined to a basement
i have dreams that i have to chase
marry him and all of our problems will
be solved it's too late
[Music]
life outside this basement starts right
now
[Music]
the glass any way you can make it more
comfortable no but you just did a whole
thing even magic has its limits
[Music]
back when we had winners i was afraid to
lose you to the competition
five times you won the all-american
that was a long time ago wasn't it
that was before the accident
before the booze
you know how many people told me to just
cut you loose
[Music]
you gonna say anything howard i've
always thought of you as a small weak
and gutless man
but you know there's no reason to be
rude
you owe me mike you gave me your word
and that used to mean something
my son rafael he's in trouble i want to
get him out of mexico
we want you to go down there and kidnap
him
please just get him back up here
just you just me
[Music]
hey rob you come out now i'm a friend
defended the family
touch me and kicked your hustle man
jesus christ
[Music]
get in the back we go and i tell you
okay
look the only place you're gonna go is
the hospital you get too angry it's not
good for you
[Music]
you used to be strong
natural
i used to be a lot of things
[Music]
but i'm not now
i'll tell you something
[Music]
this macho thing is overrated
just people trying to leave my show show
that they've got grit
that's about all they end up with
it's like anything else in life you
think you got all the answers
i'm mike
[Music]
and you realize you get older you don't
have any of them
we all have to make choices in life kid
you have to make yours
[Music]
his name is macho like me very strong
rooster whatever what's wrong with that
nothing
yeah i want to name this card macho it's
okay by me
my name is parker joe and i'm with
social services
i need police and paramedics
[Music]
had a uh female doa
i'm your social worker you got a
daughter who needs to get to school long
time
stop crying into my family i'm trying to
keep ashley from being taken away from
you
i didn't know you're getting out today
dahlia
you're the man who's been looking after
my family huh i'm back i'd love nothing
more than have to come by here anymore
prodigal son is home
caught some chatter on the inside that
might be a real score
take care of business we're going in
there for the money and the drugs
i'm worried about ashley
i'm also concerned for you
[Music]
tell me this isn't happening again
[Music]
you think you could do a big favor for
dad
[Music]
this happened here because of you you
got the cartel after all of us
why are you even helping us no one
helped me when i needed it most
they're in trouble i'm in trouble
i've seen so many families the clips
that they're about to follow from
and there's nothing i can do to stop it
you actually can help people
you have an opportunity to get something
done
[Music]
you all have to work for someone
if this was your family what would you
do
[Music]
give the agent the go-ahead miss james
okay sam we've trained for the situation
and you know what to do
mission's a go
we've been breached
[Music]
a talking ape i prefer chimp
[Music]
this is the earliest known photo of
daniel hall
he's attempting to build some sort of
new weapon
he must be stopped
have an idea we going to take over
oh attacking is that part of the plan is
now that is attacking part of the plan
to take over the world clearly you're
new to this whole evil thing when
humanity faces its greatest threat it's
imperative we have that data a careful
partner one hero
sam that's disgusting
you'll swing into action
maintaining an appropriate level of
physical training is important
please this is a serious mission
yes
don't leave me hanging i should be
running this operation me
you're one mysterious monkey don't hate
the player hate the game
my dad right madeleine keynes sophia
olanji skip schweink do that where you
going never mind i don't care take this
back to the lab saving the world
is all
monkey business
who was that funky monkey
c.i.a
[Music]
we need relevant writers that can make
us relevant again is there anyone dead
we can revive maybe but he's not dead
who
harry shaw
he's dead back her off
it's dragon
really i mean he's probably
did you know he shot his last assistant
because he mistook him for a bear oh
how is that even possible i don't you
can't believe everything oh we're not
bears we're not bears we asked danbridge
publishing believe that is your
signature so you owe us a book shut up
anything you want to show me
your pound of flesh i won't do the
bloody tour do the tour or i edit the
book those are your choices
this is a book tour why don't i read
something
bullshite [ __ ] [ __ ]
no one's interested in the book they're
interested in this freak show this man
is the book reviewer for the times i
don't like book critics and i found it
totally passed the next day
you're all evil shy
it is not selling okay no one is buying
it i can't get him to do anything all i
am to him is his driver and his scotch
sherpa let's go do you want to buy a
book
you want to know what i think
[Music]
times have changed hashtag's [ __ ]
how a book is released today has become
just as meaningful as its content eden
was gone no longer within reach god was
done with mistakes was that was too
melodramatic
you vanquished my fears and for that
i am forever grateful this may be nuts
hasn't he
i know
mr shaw what is your book about be brave
be truthful
even the worst of us get lucky
somehow you have over 20 000 followers
christ had followers it didn't end well
for him bible was a bestseller wasn't it
[Music]
you